aux 319 de monsieur ambroise dupont
monsieur le ministre d'intérieur
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
merci d'être là pour me répondre mes
chers collègues je voudrais monsieur le
ministre évoqué un sujet technique
important pour les collectivités locales
qui est celui de la défense incendie
dans les communes
attendu depuis 2004 avec intérêt par les
professionnels de la sécurité des élus
elle a connu une évolution notable grâce
à l'une des dispositions de l'article 77
de la loi 2011-12 en 2 525 du 17 mai
2011 de simplification et d'amélioration
de la qualité du droit
ce texte codifiée au code général des
collectivités territoriales a permis de
confirmer préciser les règles de la
défense extérieure contre l' incendie
ainsi que la répartition des compétences
les conditions de l'application
toutefois sont renvoyées à un décret
relatif à l'aménagement l'entretien la
vérification des points d'eau servant à
l'alimentation des moyens de lutte
contre l' incendie ainsi qu'un
référentiel national de défense
extérieure contre la 110 et cela tarde
très singulièrement à être publié vous
le savez monsieur le ministre de
nombreux élus ont de longue date
souhaitait une clarification des
compétences et souligné l'inadéquation
de la réglementation en vigueur en
matière de lutte contre l'incendié par
rapport aux réalités locales très
disparates notamment dans le cas de
l'habitat dispersé dans les territoires
ruraux
en effet dans l'incapacité d'assurer un
débit suffisant
certaines collectivités rurales se
retrouve contrainte d'engager des
investissements particulièrement coûteux
pour se doter de réservoirs d'eau alors
qu'une adaptation haut débit produit par
les réseaux d'eau potable pourrait dans
certains cas remédier aux exigences de
la défense extérieure contre l'incendié
c'est donc tout l'enjeu de ce texte que
de permettre aux acteurs en particulier
les maires et les présidents de pays
d'ajuster les débits en fonction des
circonstances locales risques identifiés
caractéristiques locales du bâti ou de
l'urbanisation dans le cadre d'une
fourchette définie de débit et de
volumes en os devant être disponibles
les mesures d'application de la réforme
relative à la défense contre les
incendies
sont depuis longtemps annoncée comme
imminente mais toujours reporté malgré
l'avis favorable du bureau de
l'association des maires de la
commission consultative d'évaluation des
normes en 2012
les maires sur le terrain relayé par les
associations d'élus s'inquiète de ces
retards alors monsieur le ministre je
vous serais vraiment reconnaissant de
bien vouloir nous préciser quand ces
mesures entreront effectivement en
vigueur
et quand celle ci semble toujours
suspens et alors que celle ci semble
toujours suspendu à l'avis du conseil
d'état qui constitue a priori la
dernière étape du processus
merci monsieur le ministre
ainsi monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur vous m'interrogez sur la
réforme de la défense contre l'incendié
même si aujourd'hui on parle plutôt de
la neige dans votre département en tout
cas soyez assurés que l'ensemble des
services de l'état en lien avec les
collectivités territoriales font tout
pour que la situation redevienne normale
dans ce département comme dans bien
d'autres votre question témoigne de la
forte attente je dirais même de la
légitime impatience
de nombreux élus à voir enfin aboutir la
réforme de la défense extérieure contre
l'incendié
je vous remercie de relayer ses
préoccupations au sein de cette
assemblée
je réaffirme devant vous ma volonté de
mener à bien ce projet engagé depuis
plusieurs années depuis 2005
aussi je tiens en premier lieu à vous
informer de l'état d'avancement de la
réforme comme vous le soulignez comme
vous le savez
l'article 77 de la loi du 17 mai 2011 à
codifier codifiée par nos code général
des collectivités territoriales a fixé
le nouveau cadre législatif de ce
domaine son décret d'application est
prêt il avait d'ailleurs reçu début 2012
des avis favorables de tous les
organismes consultatifs intéressés en
particulier celui de la commission
consultative d'évaluation des normes
j'ajouterai que le bureau l'association
des maires de france soutient également
ce projet le texte a été déposé devant
le conseil d'état
il ya presque un an en avril 2012 mais
il n'a pu être examinée avant le
changement de gouvernement j'ai donc
relancé la procédure d'adoption du
décret dès l'été dernier mais en
préalable à la saisine du conseil d'état
nous avons dû consulter les ministères
contre signataires du nouveau
gouvernement
cette procédure s'achève enfin elle nous
permettra de présenter très
prochainement le texte devant le conseil
d'état
c'est l'ultime étape avant sa signature
et sa publication
j'ajoute que ce décret sera complété par
un catalogue de solutions techniques à
disposition les acteurs territoriaux
il s'agit du référentiel national de la
défense extérieure contre l' incendie
prix sous forme d'arrêté en second lieu
pour vous répondre sur le fond
sachez que la réforme pour objectif
d'éclaircir le plus précisément possible
le rôle des différents intervenants dans
ce domaine comme vous le rappelez la
gestion de ce service public et le
pouvoir de police administrative
spéciale liés sont désormais
transférables aux établissements publics
de coopération intercommunale en
pratique ce transfert effectué sur la
base du volontariat dégagera les maires
en particulier ceux des communes rurales
de toute responsabilité dans ce domaine
ce transfert total s'effectuera au
profit de structures en capacités
techniques et juridiques d'organiser
cette compétence qui est
particulièrement complexe
en outre la loi comme le futur décret
sépare bien ce qui relève du service de
l'eau potable de ce qui relève de la
défense incendie
les financements respectifs de ces deux
services publics sont par conséquent
scinder le décret le référentiel
national préciseront les interactions
juridique et technique entre ces deux
services
vous avez évoqué également monsieur le
sénateur l'impossibilité de
surdimensionner dans les zones rurales
les réseaux d'eau potable au profit de
la défense incendie
sans entrer dans le détail sinon le
pression me rappellera l'ordre sachez
qu'il existe des solutions techniques
pour utiliser
malgré tout les capacités de ce type de
réseau sans abaisser le niveau de
sécurité
enfin précisons que les réseaux d'eau
potable ne sont pas l'unique ressource
en eau de la défense extérieure contre
les incendies les citernes ou les points
d'eau naturels peuvent notamment être
également utilisée pour ces cas des
solutions pragmatiques
seront trouvées grâce à la collaboration
de tous les acteurs concernés par la
défense incendie
les services d'incendié et de secours
les collectivités territoriales ou
encore les opérateurs de réseaux d'eau
acteur à qui je veux rendre hommage
ce partenariat est à la fois promu est
rendue obligatoire par la réforme
il est la clé du développement d'une
défense incendie raisonnée vous avez
compris mais sur le sénateur je souhaite
maintenant que le plus vite possible aux
rythmes évidemment du conseil d'état
mais je ne doute pas que ça ira vite
cette réforme puisse véritablement
rentrer désormais en application
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
dupont oui merci monsieur le ministre
j'ai fait un point exhaustif de la
situation historique si je puis dire
parce que non seulement elle ça remonte
à 2005 mais depuis 1985 2155 genou nous
nous nous sommes régis par c'est par ces
articles et par ses lois donc c'est vrai
c'est vraiment indispensable je dirais
d'autant plus que au plan de l'urbanisme
on est en train de passer vers les play
pluie inter communaux ou inter ne
communauté de communes et que la
compétence pouvant être transféré les
communes qui n'ont plus ce pouvoir se
trouvent tous complètement démunis est
incapable d'assurer un petit
développement même de remplir les dents
creuses
j'ai bien conscience qu'il faut pas
construire partout n'importe comment
donc monsieur le ministre vous avez fait
un point très exhaustif on en est
toujours au même point
et donc je voudrais bien qu'à l'époque
où les marronniers fleurissent vous
fassiez mourir celui là